okay so good morning everyone and thanks
for coming to this morning session so
you have two talks and then a break
maybe more toxin and run it's a very
brutal schedule Thanks I make much to
talk okay so the first speaker is
michael lu b i'm sure you all know who's
from Qualcomm and he's going to talk
about coding theory for scale will live
it will be working out for quite some
time forever forever I thought I'd be
you know it's we're supposed to be
practice to theory so I thought I'd do
some real practice but I will do
everything should be accessible to
everybody today so I'm not going to do
anything very difficult at all in fact
uh I like this thing that a menace said
yesterday who was it yes he said your
your your goal is not to cover a lot of
material you goes to uncover a little
bit so I'm going to probably uncover
very little bit but i will give you sort
of a kind of a practical perspective so
this is kind of where my ruled lives
there's application layer erasure coding
compliments traditional error correcting
era cody so i think a lot of people you
probably know this everybody in this
audience knows this picture very well
when people talk about Ford error
correction often what they're thinking
about is really physical layer error
correction era coating and that's the
vast majority of current use of FPC is
probably what you're it not only you
guys but everybody else is familiar with
it's typically applied at layers one and
two and it's usually performed in
hardware you know you have physical
layer forward error correction what
we're talking about today is really
erasure coding is not it says relatively
new i don't know if it's all that new at
this point but it's still not nearly as
popular as error correction that's for
sure it's definitely it doesn't replace
era coding in any way is kind of a
layered thing they're very complementary
to each other just as I'll describe
on the next slide it's typically
performed in software and it's called
application layer for do correction so
just so everybody's you know really
simple stuff this is how it really works
you've got packets IP packets typically
and you have a header on there an IP
header but you also have an FPC header
that describes what's inside the packet
so if you have corruption when it's sent
over the network of any kind what
happens is the lower layers discard it
and it's erased and so what you get is
the set of packets with the header and
you can identify what's in the package
from the packet header and that's why
it's really the erasure channel is
relevant okay and then the idea behind
application layer erasure codes as you
all know is you have source data you
break it into source symbols sometimes
you have multiple source symbols per
packet sometimes you don't and then you
encode it by generating repair symbols
you packet eyes it you transmit it UD
packet eyes which is this is a step
where you understand which pieces of the
data which symbols you actually receive
so that's why it's an erasure channel
and then you recover the original source
data by a ratio decoding so this is
probably this kind of for me explains
the relationship between application for
Derek correction and physically FEC at
least in sort of a broadcast channel
which is basically what I'm going to be
focusing on today so the application
layer FEC provides packard protection
over small to large blocks it has very
flexible time diversity and a flexible
amount of protection because it's at the
application layer right so you can
encode and decode large quantities of
data so flexible time diversity of
protection from sub-second two hours
potentially of protection on the other
hand the physical layer FEC is actually
doing something much more difficult it
actually has to find the errors isn't
know where the errors are it has to try
to correct those and discard the
corrupted packet with high reliability
if it's actually got uncorrectable
errors in it and this is typically over
a small interval x sub second typically
and it's a fixed amount of protection
because it the implementation of all
that is in hardware or firmware so
here's kind of how they work together
you have some signal to noise ratio and
actually what typically happens with the
physical FEC is that some it kind of has
this brick wall we're above this it
corrects and below this it has to
discard things they can't correct right
and so the basic idea behind the erasure
coding is to encode at the as a higher
level and you have you break up your
your packet stream into a source block
and repair resource source packets and
repair packets and then when the signal
is bad you lose those parts but when
it's good enough you receive those
packets right and then the idea is that
you lose a little bit of your your rate
but we've done is you cleaned up the
channel so you actually take something
that has maybe a potentially high error
rate and cleaned it up in just something
that has a much lower potential even
zero error rate ideally
so so for example in this all this kind
of an old example here but you had a 5.3
megabit per second channel with a
14-percent packet error rate and you've
cleaned it up to have a reduced rate 4.3
megabit per second channel but now your
your error rate is essentially zero yes
about feedback is this in these channels
so there's all kinds of networks
channels in the ones that I'm going to
be talking about later there was
absolutely no feedback from anywhere it
I actually there is and there will be a
little bit but it's sort of indirect and
it's on a different time scale right
it's it's not at the level of the
networking kind of layer so what I'm so
what with this kind of refers to is a
case where you really have a a broadcast
channel you don't have a you're not
working over the internet so eck
acknowledgement absolutely not there's
no tcp acknowledge earth either as
there's not tcp UDP yes just from the
general way to describe it so it's
analogous to concatenation I guess I
mean your application layer is kind of
do it you talked about it cleaning up to
this yes yes yeah and that yeah it's
kind of like one but it's kind of good
to keep those layers so people have sort
of thought about oh why don't we try to
combine these two things together right
through the erasure and the error
correction together and in theory that's
a great problem to work on in practice
there's all kinds of reasons that just
will never work I mean maybe it will
work in some future version of some
system you have to redesign the whole
thing and in fact there is good
principles you know i have actually i'll
describe a little bit later i've worked
in the standards area quite a bit not
that much but a little bit and I
understood from this that there's really
good reasons that there's layers in the
architecture because you can kind of
take out one replace it with something
else without disturbing everything else
and if you don't have that kind of
architecture you kind of get stuck into
the
monolithic thing and nothing can ever
change okay so I think everybody in this
audience knows what a fountain code is
so I'm not really going to go into that
but essentially it's just you can keep
generating it's a systematic fountain
code has the property that the original
source is part of the encoding but you
can generate repair symbols as long as
you want essentially without really any
time or complexity penalty or anything
like that so it's kind of an on-demand
code you can just keep asking for more
symbols and you can get them and I think
you're all probably familiar with LT and
coding so I'll just kind of flip for
these sides but essentially the idea is
it's very simple right you just take
random linear combinations of source
symbols in the in the simplest form out
of it and you XOR them together and
that's what you send in the non-systemic
version of it and it's really the whole
idea behind how it works and why it
works is behind this probability
distribution which is how you choose
these degrees with certain probabilities
so for example you choose the degree to
be two with probably fifty percent
probably three was seventeen percent in
this example and so on and the whole
idea you're doing that is to so make
sure with high probability that belief
propagation decoding works and recovers
with the mint amount of reception so you
don't need to receive many additional
packets beyond the size of the regional
source block to recover with high
probability and this really the belief
propagation part is just make sure that
the decoding complexity is equal equal
to the encoding complexity which is
equal to the number of symbol operations
you have to do with belief propagation
decoding is equal to the number of edges
in this graph right you can see by how
it works that every time you do a belief
propagation decoding your you're dealing
with one edge you're removing that edge
for the next step and use this keep
going so as you go along you can see
a that the total complexity is
proportional to the number of edges in
the graph and that's both for the
encoder and decoder so I'm not going to
go through any of the fear anything as I
said I'm going to make this talk really
really simple and I think probably a lot
of you know more about the details than
I do but that this is one intuition that
maybe you have or have not seen so maybe
this one is worth thinking about a bit
so there's this degree distribution
which says what's the probability that
you choose an encoding symbol of a
certain degree and the intuition about
why you pick a certain degree
distribution is well at at some point
the encoding symbol releases and what
does it mean to release you recover all
of its neighbors but one so it's got
exactly one neighbor left right if it's
degree D and you're kind of decoding and
its neighbors are the ones that are
being decoded or random you expect to
use that encoding it's usable with when
a fraction of something like 1 over d of
the source symbols are remaining right
because that's the kind of the point
where you've kind of recovered all but
one of its neighbors right so it says
it's kind of useful when approximately 1
over d of its neighbors are left so if
you kind of dedicate the degree d guys
to cover the interval between the D
minus 1 and D you get a 1 over d times d
minus 1 like interval right and that
sort of says that's what the probability
of choosing a degree D should be so that
kind of gives you some intuition why
these this ideal Salton distribution has
this probability of degree D as 1 over d
times d minus 1 is just the interval of
space between for example of degree 3
it's this interval of probability
between one half and one third because
intuitively you're going to use degree
three guys to recover here you're going
to use degree for guys to recover here
and this is how much you need to recover
and so on so that's an intuition turns
out the reality is a little different so
you know for example one half has got
some slope to it with all these
polynomials but nevertheless when you
add them all up it does turn out to be
uniform release distribution and here's
one other simple very simple thing about
choosing from the soliton distribution
which I don't know I kind of like it
because it's about as simple as you can
get one way to choose from is just
choose a random number between 0 and 1
uniformly and then just take the inverse
of that and round it up and if it's
bigger than 1 over K and make it equal
to your degree one guy so so that's a
very simple way to choose from this and
there's some other interesting things
you can analyze from that okay so let me
shift gears a little bit and go to much
more practical things so so over the
years we've worked on these so alt codes
and then we had raptor codes and then
raptor q codes so these are codes that
have been standardized in the various
standards groups for example the
internet IETF so the Raptor codes were
the first this is this RFC 5053 RFC
stands for requests for comments and
that code has been also adopted into a
variety of other standards around the
world these are systemic fountain codes
they have linear time encoding and
decoding they have very good recovery
properties like a random G up to and
pretty good flexibility they specify up
to 8,000 source symbols and up to 65,000
total encoded symbols and then the
newest newer generation are these Raptor
cucos which are also systematic and have
very fast encoding and decoding and they
have really good recovery properties
like a random code / GF 256 even though
they are when you're encoding and
decoding and we've specified
standardized ease up to around fifty six
thousand source symbols and essentially
an unlimited number of encoded symbols
more than you would actually ever really
need so I'm not going to go into the
details of this but these are kind of
the major technical features that are
involved
these codes so only one small component
hi Ellie is the LT code part which was
incorporated as an essential feature of
the Raptor RFC 5053 but that's not
nearly enough right because if you just
do the belief propagation with LT codes
you're not going to get anything that's
really practical and it to be honest it
drives me crazy that people still out
there in the research community still
write about LT and compare their code
against that as if though that's the
best one out there it's like so it
there's a thing called precoding which
is you know you add LDPC and actually
have an htpc layer as well in that was
all in the Raptor RFC 1553 that actually
makes sure that it really has the high
the it's invertible with high
probability and then it has something
called inactivation decoding which
essentially means you're doing Gaussian
elimination so you would decode if you
can right so there's there's no if it's
decodable you don't get stuck just
because belief propagation gets stuck
somewhere you keep going and you kind of
solve the thing when it's solvable no
matter what so the the probability that
it's full rank is exactly the
probability you're going to decode and
then it's also incorporated this
systematic construction which includes
the original source i'll tell you in the
original form where we try to propose
these codes in 3gpp be on the ITF we ran
into problems because we only have the
non-systematic construction at that
point and then all these companies came
forward and said no we demand that any
code we're going to accept has to be
systematic and so that led to a rush of
research which led to the systematic
construction and then so those are all
in 1553 going beyond that in raptor q it
has two additional elements to make it
really strong one is obviously in the
incorporation of larger finite fields
but those aren't sprinkled in there in a
very sparse way so really does
in effect the complexity there's only a
very few equations that are over G of
256 a vast majority of its still over GF
2 so the encoding decoding is still
super fast but it really significantly
reduces the reception overhead and the
error curve is much much much better it
also to sort of work in conjunction with
that there's this idea of permanent and
activation which really reduce the
reception overhead nificant Lee as well
so if you want to read more about this
there's this monograph that amine and I
wrote if you send me a personal email I
will reply with the actual full version
of this and it's in color not the black
and white which is what you get if you
buy the book did you specify how you do
the end of activation is I guessing or
is it kind of you leave it up to them to
do it actually if you read this it
really describes pretty much almost
exactly how to do it we actually had
some debate about how much we should
describe that because you describe to
the curry like configured oh yeah yeah
but we did do a pretty thorough job and
this was all on Qualcomm time so it was
kind of I spent a month over and
switzerland with a mean ladies yeah it
was terrible it was terrible okay so
complexity you can see is the you know
reed-solomon code versus raptor this is
much faster it stays Linear's as the
size grows and the velocity on this is
one of the main reasons why rap to Q is
better so what this shows is the number
of encoded symbols you received beyond
case 0 0 means you received exactly the
number of source symbols in the original
source block and with Raptor code we
have this upper bound on it which you
know goes down sort of like a random GF
to a little bit slower but essentially
like a random GF to code with Raptor Q
you get a much much tighter error curve
here so a0 overhead and we've tested
this you know billions and billions of
trials with different error
probabilities over all the different
source block lengths yes okay and and it
adds
overhead it decodes fails to decode only
1% and every time every extra symbol
goes down by a factor of 100 so it
really is almost like an MDS code I'll
just say one word spent a lot of time in
the ITF actually defining the whole
suite of protocols so I could
incorporate the Raptor and Raptor Q into
that and that suite of protocols has
actually been adopted into every
broadcast service layer that I know of
around the world for mobile at least
including LTE broadcast so it has this
suite of protocols that we defined in
the ITF and it's used for broadcast file
delivery but interestingly enough it's
also used for streaming services so
you're using file delivery protocols for
streaming in the over the LTE broadcast
system and one other thing that we did a
lot of work on in MPEG was this dash
lead dynamic adoptee streaming over HTTP
and that is also being adopted into LTE
broadcast for doing the streaming and
interesting enough the reason for doing
that is because that's what's being used
for streaming over the internet at this
point how many of you think you've used
dash before
okay how many of you watch Netflix how
many of you done a YouTube okay how many
of you now think you've used dash before
okay so that's really what everybody's
been converging to this in HL s HL s is
the Apple version of what they've
defined for adopting streaming dash is
the one we have a consortium of
companies around that kind of have
converged to that and hopefully a one
day everybody converges to 1 solution
but we're almost there but anyway the
reason for doing this here is because
they see it here and they want to have
converged services right so you can do
something over broadcast and also do it
over HTTP and have a system that goes
back and forth so how much time do I
have no time all right okay so this part
is why fountain code so one of the
things that I you know the Raptor Raptor
Q are nice because they can deal with
large numbers of source symbols and do
efficient encoding decoding but is this
fountain property really important so
I'm not going to convince you totally
but all maybe give you some ideas behind
why it might be interesting to have that
kind of thing so this is when I talked
about before this LTE broadcast system
this by the way started back in two
thousand six for the original standard
and we're all hoping that was going to
take off it didn't so now there's a new
round which has a little bit more
promise of taking off I know where
there's some deployments around the
world at this point that are starting
off but this is really a cellular
broadcast solution LTE broadcast
solution for streaming and delivery of
popular content it really offloading
that content from the HTTP internet and
so here's an interesting application of
a raptor queue or fountain code in
general idea for using this service so
the idea is you have an original content
just foreplay example I have ten source
symbols there and now you only broadcast
the repair symbols you don't broadcast
the original source you just broadcast
the repair and what do you do that we've
got some device which if it receives at
least ten symbols here it can decode
right then you're happy but what if it
receives less now what do you do do you
schedule another broadcast session do
you throw all this data we see do the
broadcast network away I do something
else well really what you do is
something else so in this case you can't
decode if you receive less than 10 but
the idea is that you have the same
content available over the internet over
HTTP right and so this device only
received five repair symbols this one
received nine this one received seven so
what do they do well what they can do is
this first guy is missing five it just
makes an HTTP request for a prefix of
the content that's equal to five symbols
worth right so symbols say a thousand
bytes and asked for the first five
thousand bytes of the content receives
that treated as source symbols and
decodes the next one needs one bite are
one symbol of content but actually it's
can ask for the same thing that the
first one asks for just prefix so it
asks for a little bit less and so on and
so what you get here is this really nice
feature that even though these guys
receive different symbols here in
different patterns in different amounts
what they need to do is only ask the
HTTP edge cache server for prefix of the
thing of the of the content and that's
really good for the HTTP infrastructure
because asking for the same content
again and again and the cash on the edge
is really good for cache performance and
really good for recovery properties it
also means they don't have to store the
entire file on the edge there's just a
portion of it the longest prefix is
enough let me give you another quick
example I know I'm going to get kicked
out in a second
um how many seconds five minutes okay so
a similar example so you have a Content
package which you're trying to deliver
which consists of media content a B and
C and I just made them all the same size
of each ten symbols in size so there's
30 symbols total now let's suppose
through one way or another device one
has a and B device to has B and C and
device three has a and C so I can use
the same solution as before but now I'm
going to broadcast the repair symbols in
this case I'm only going to for example
broadcast ten symbols which is much
shorter than the total package right but
those and let's suppose there's no
laughs in this case so all these devices
receive these ten civils right but now
you see they can all decode right
because they've got all but because it's
a systematic cove these are symbols of
the original thing these are different
symbols of the original content and
these are different subset of symbols so
combining those big pair symbols even
though they're the same repair symbols
they can all decode so this gives a nice
by the way this idea was from Jack wolf
and I mean chakra relay from a few years
ago so it's a very cute nice idea of how
to use this thing so the last thing I
wanted to talk about and I know I'm kind
of running out of time it's supposed to
be a practical session here so I brought
a real working demo and maybe Lawrence
can come up and get it to work so
Lawrence is actually the guy who not
only wrote all the Raptor code by the
way but he also implemented this
application you're going to let me you
trust me to hit the the right one okay
okay good so what you see here I'll tell
you what it is in a second so you see
here is just a movie and we actually
this is just free content so we you know
we there's no licensing rights here
thank God but you see when i hit the
sikh button how fast it started again
and if i do that again I'll seek over
here immediately comes up i do seek back
here immediately comes up if i do seek
here comes up immediately so that's the
point the movie is not stored in its
original form what we did for this
because we we broadcast in simulate a
broadcasting just repair symbols so what
we did is we sent the repair symbols to
the device over UDP we actually induce
loss on those symbols just to make it
realistic twenty thirty percent loss and
then what we did is when receiving them
we just wrote them to the SD card the
original repair symbols not the decoded
content so as they come in you fill up
your SD card and then when the player
wants to play back the media it goes
back and reads the appropriate portion
where you seek to and just reason those
symbols and decodes on the fly and send
it to the player employs it so what
you're actually seeing there was raptor
q in you go back to the previous
do I have the
yeah so here's what the parameters were
so it was the 91 megabyte file is
partitioned into ten source blocks about
nine by nine megabytes each but those
who are furthest apart ition did two
sub-blocks about 223 kilobytes each so
the symbol size is 36 bytes and there's
about 6,300 source symbols in each time
we're doing the decoding so what it was
decoding when you seek was a sub-block
of 223 kilobytes each symbol of 36 bytes
and it's got 6300 symbols and it's doing
that in essentially real time so you
really can't tell the difference between
doing this and when you've so so what's
the advantage of this so typically what
you do in a broadcast you send the whole
thing interleave because you're trying
to get the best protection against
packet loss right so you send this whole
thing mixed up in early jazz much as
possible and then when you receive on
the device typically what you do is a
post processing step where you bring the
whole thing in the memory decoded and
write it back to the flash drive right
so there's two problems with that first
of all it's a long time after you
receive until you can play it back
because this post processing if it's a
big file takes a long time and second of
all you're writing twice to the to the
flash and as we heard earlier these
flashes don't have a long life life to
them so the less you write to them the
better if you read that's not a problem
but if you keep writing to it that's a
problem so what this does is as soon as
you deliver the as soon as you finish
the broadcast delivery the content is
accessible and actually on the fly
you're only decoding the parts of the
end users ever consuming so you can do
this all in very fast kind of real-time
okay I think I'm out of time thank you
any questions maybe you have time for
any of its my back here I detail
question yes are you using the
systematic Raptor code and then sending
just the parity symbols for it yes yeah
okay you never send the systematic well
using some of your applications like you
hadn't requested this is the parts
listen I out because it's not a code for
that to work right yes absolutely you
need the systematic code for that to
work for those examples I gave where one
guy has a B and that was you know so
what you're doing is you could come you
might think that those other files were
downloaded over the internet using
standard HTTP right so that part of the
infrastructures doesn't have to know
anything about coding the only part
using coding is when you broadcast it
but you can combine the broadcast with
normal HTTP Internet services in a kind
of seamless way without the internet
ever knowing about kony using gaussian
elimination india's stuck yes do you
still get linear time so you do and
that's what this inactivation decoding
is you kind of set aside a equation if
you can't solve and say oh camera to
solve that later and just keep going and
you using the wave propagation so you
sort of set one aside so you had a
degree to guy say all I can't solve
because I need a degree one guy set one
of those guys aside and keep going
because now you got a degree to one guy
and then you kind of keep going and you
eliminate the other part and you solve
this part here and you go back and so
it's a little more complicated than I
think the fine is that is the size of
that is bounded by the square root I see
so you don't baby yeah so the number of
in of act in activations you do is
limited yeah you don't keep that's you
still need it to be most of the time
belief propagation to work but when you
get stuck you don't get stuck you just
keep going the square root yes yeah yeah
in fact more than alice's in reality
I got a constant so why did they insist
on systematic for lots of reasons and I
agree with them complete with this boy
at that point I was really pissed off
but at this point because nobody likes
something which they don't understand
just may be the main I mean right but
then there turns out there's all these
other applications and ideas you can use
if you really have the systemic part so
it really makes sense yes that's in one
if some receivers don't have a decoder
but some do you don't want to punish the
ones that don't as an example okay okay
okay thanks much